ein Jurist der im Gefängnis sitzt
721 so viele Tage ist Herr Brinkmann
noch in Haft im offenen Vollzug in der
JVA Bielefeld Senne erzählt sie jeden
einzelnen Tag
wegen Betrugs wurde er zu vier Jahren
verurteilt da war er Ende 50
das ist sein Haftraum den er sich mit
einem anderen teilt nach einem
Herzinfarkt ist Herr Brinkmann nun im
Gefängnis für sogenannte lebensältere
untergebracht viele Männer im
Rentenalter die schon lange sitzen
oder aber erst im Alter ins Gefängnis
kamen wie Herr Brinkmann statt Arbeiten
in der Anwaltskanzlei verpackt er nun
Büromaterial für die JVA
zu Menschen macht immer sinnvolles und
ist diszipliniert ja Grundlage des des
Vollzugs meiner Meinung Disziplin die
man normal leben ja nur begrenzt am Tag
gelegt hat ist aber nicht straffällig
geworden Herr Brinkmann empfindet diesen
Bruch in seinem Leben als zweite Chance
und will draußen alles besser machen
auch den Schaden den er angerichtet hat
wieder gut machen
wenn ich irgendwann draußen arbeite und
mehr verdienen kann dann kann ich davon
auch ein Teil zurückführen
so ist der Plan denn im offenen Vollzug
darf er irgendwann auch draußen arbeiten
offener Vollzug hier heißt auch sich
frei bewegen im gefängnispark nur dieser
dünne Zaun trennt von draußen
auf dem Gelände gibt es sogar ein
kleines Kirchenkaffee
und Gottesdienste in der gefängniskirche
und eine Seelsorgerin die sich die
Ängste und Sorgen anhört von den älteren
Inhaftierten
wer als alter Mensch ins Gefängnis kommt
nach einem völlig straffreien
bürgerlichen Leben der der landet
derartig auf einem Boden von Tatsachen
von denen vorher nie sicher träumen
lassen ist da hier mal landet und wer
Jahrzehnte lang in Haft war hat draußen
keinerlei Bindung und findet sich auch
draußen sehr schlecht zurecht der offene
Vollzug bietet zwar die Möglichkeit
stundenweise nach draußen zu gehen oder
auch mal draußen zu übernachten nach
einigen Monaten wenn man sich da bewährt
hat in diesen Stufen
aber damit hat man ja noch nicht das
Gefühl auf eigenen Füßen draußen sein
Leben zu organisieren und da haben viele
ein riesen Bammel vor auch hier hilft
die JVA Wohnungssuche Pflegestufe
beantragen und noch mehr
wie sieht das aus mit der mit der
Schuldnerberatung jeweils die wollen
mich anschreiben jetzt war ich auf der
Sparkasse gewesen aber die Gläubiger
Liste hatten wir jetzt ja fertig ne
auch die Beamten und Beamten wie Herr
Bernd haben ein offenes Ohr für die
älteren Inhaftierten
was macht ihr Rücken
weichere Matratzen Handläufe duschstühle
ein EKG die Menschen werden immer älter
das heißt eben auch mehr Haftplätze für
alte Menschen
wir haben auch hier den Fall dass wir
zum Beispiel den Pflegedienst oft hier
haben weil einige Gefangene nicht mehr
in der Lage sind sich selber
zu waschen oder sich zu versorgen der
älteste auf Abteilung D aktuell 84
ist Mitte 60 kurz vor der Rente möchte
auch seinen Teil zur JVA beitragen und
arbeitet in der Gefängnisbibliothek hier
sind die Gesetzestexte wer dann auch
noch mal seine
Sachen bearbeiten will er ist gelernter
Ingenieur seither in Haft ist holt er
akribisch seine Steuererklärungen nach
ja das sind ist eine von 42
Steuererklärung
die jetzt alle fertig sind ja eigentlich
arbeite ich da schon drei Jahre dran ich
bin
steuerstraftäter ich habe hier die Haft
die Isolation in der Haft dazu genutzt
konzentriert alles abzuarbeiten was ich
versäumt habe damit ich klar Schiff
machen kann und
angesichts meines Alters dann auch ihr
diesen Bereich abschließen meine Frau
unterstützt mich da stark bei auch die
Steuerschulden zu tilgen was uns schon
zur Hälfte auch gelungen ist und wir
werden auch die zweite Hälfte
bezahlen das ist für mich noch ein sehr
letztes Lebensziel woher nimmt er den
Glauben dass alles gut wird nie Balla
ist eigentlich aus der Kirche
ausgetreten am Anfang seiner Haft vor
zwei Jahren saß er 17 Tage in Isolation
nur mit einer Bibel ich hatte nur das
Neue Testament und das Ergebnis dieser
Arbeit sehen Sie hier ich habe die
durchgearbeitet und festgestellt dass
die Bibel das beste Erfolgsbuch für
Manager ist wenn du jemanden eine Schuld
zu bezahlen hast einige dich schnell mit
deinem Gegner solange du noch mit ihm
auf dem Wege zum Gericht bist sonst wird
er dich den Richter ausliefern und er
wird dich dem Gerichtsdiener übergeben
und du kommst ins Gefängnis ich
versichere dir du kommst erst dann
wieder raus wenn du den letzten Cent
bezahlt hast
so das lesen Sie dann im Gefängnis
Klasse hätte ich schon eher wissen
müssen
zu verlieren bleibt optimistisch
wobei das jetzt noch nicht eine
Endstadium ist was das Leben angeht
sondern ich bin der positiv gestimmt
eben nach dieser Bereinigung eben auch
wieder
meinen Beruf nachzugehen den ich sehr
liebe trotz seines Alters das ist sein
Ziel hier raus in zwei Jahren und dann
weitermachen